comme on s'y attendait c'est pas qu'on
bâtit sur mouvement pour donner le goût
de lire aux jeunes le 14 mai temps où et
intéresser les jeunes à la lecture c'est
l'objectif du mouvement à go on lit avec
ses quatre ambassadeurs que vous voyez
bien connu mehdi moussaïd anne marie
anna mazza pierre yves roy desmarais et
l'humoriste et animateur qui est vaine
raphaël qui étaient avec nous d'ailleurs
ce matin bonjour keven ça va très bien
les moulins donc à go on lit je pensais
vous voir devant la bibliothèque remplie
de livres mais non mais j'en ai apporté
à me suis dit regarde c'est ce que
j'aime capable d'aller maintenant
beaucoup marc bourgie c'est vraiment
l'fun parce que s'il pourra encourager
les jeunes à la lecture puis déçu aussi
de trouver leur type de lecteur pour
faire en sorte que les jeunes 10 mai
d'attribuer plus à la lecture des gens
comme maza comme pierre ils voient des
mares et des excellents lecteurs et à
des gens comme moi qui font partie des
gens qui sont des moins bons lecteurs
que six tomes sont plus difficiles mais
qu on se disait être c'est quoi au juste
au moins essayer je pense que c'est ce
que mon message à moi tac porte parole
aux jeunes c'est ça spot soit post par
un bon ça se soit rien pas bon mais t'as
aucun choix de ne point essayez donc est
et cela sans dire où était moi je vis en
lit par moi j'essaye mais au moins les
relie pour un mois s'est-elle pas dit
s'il veut pas idée mais je devais faire
pour encourager les jeunes parce que je
sais que le pain qui m'écrivent sur
instagram son camp ok le moi j'ai de la
misère là dessus fait le mouche
friendster instagram
je demande est-ce que vous avez des
trucs pour les jeunes avec succès donc
seulement donc c'est pour les jeunes de
14 à 20 ans vous et pour vous c'est plus
difficile la lecture à cet âge là
c'était comment est-ce que vous arriviez
à lire des romans à lire certains livres
c'est un jeu mais je disais légumes
comme obligé de l'est moi j'aime
beaucoup madame christiane hohmann
crétois maladie forces et mes profs à
l'école j'aime beaucoup il c'est grâce à
eux je suis ici même et les
livre j'étais obligé de liste de très
difficile pour moi moi je suis
traumatisé par artemis folle artemis
fowl j'en fais des cauchemars rapport
aujourd'hui mais lire des trucs de sport
hockey le magazine
la biographie de jacques foix à personne
que j'ai lu andré le géant qui est
toujours comme dalé mais moi ça me
pesait tribu parce que c'est ça mon
champ d'intérêt et c'est ce à quoi on
lit on essaie de trouver des livres
d'art ton champ intérieur de sa part le
coin bleu à goal.com walter bau ou
romantico les ai vus il ya un quiz donc
avec plusieurs questions pour déterminer
le genre de lecteurs qu'on ait fait j'ai
vu ça le bo romantico j'ai eu la même le
même profil on est simplement mais j'ai
pas trop compris par exemple ce que ça
voulait dire c'est l'iphone parce que
peut-on aller passer y avait fait quatre
cinq questions comme moins de question
que cette année ça devait aussi les
lecteurs cette hausse c'est à david
elliptique pouvait lire bon last année à
9,4 sont devant et puis c'est le fun à
faire en famille ou tout seul chez vous
ce temps s'est retrouvé sur la gueule
points 7 rebonds
voici les livres qui me proposait sa
dépréciation de lecture associés aux
différents profils
exactement je passe tous les livres
qu'il donne qui te donne mais à la fin
de la journée au moins qui te propose
quelque chose de mou c'est tout ce que
j'avais j'aurais eu besoin plus jeune qu
on distingue un toit la triperie
peut-être sur ces ligues le oui
effectivement faire en terminant keven
peut-être un conseil que vous fait
donner aux jeunes qui nous regardent ce
matin pour peut-être leur donner goût de
commencer aujourd'hui où cette semaine à
ouvrir un livre les jeunes je vous parle
à vous offrir
- je lis tout choquée l'ailette il bouge
les dix pages comprend une heure je suis
le père lecteurs de l'histoire de
l'humanité
même si ce que j'ai c'est le goût
d'essayer donc je te conseille je te
souhaite parce que c'est qu'elle mange
faut essayer pour réussir donc et c'est
le demandent de l'aide et papa
j'utilisais les trucs de lecture comme
prenant un surligneur poursuivre les
mots ou y aller une page à la fois moi
je suis le bug écrit daly parce que je
comprends pas les mots donc voici sens
de lecture
c'est le fun c'est pour tout le monde
j'étais capable de réussir j'adore
donc à go on lit pendant les prochaines
semaines on va vendre des capsules du
genre dans les médias sociaux dont un
petit peu partout pour initier les
jeunes à lire à prendre vos trucs merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous à queven
merci ouais tout pour une autre beau
romantico excellent à la prochaine